字幕: Neeta Bhansali
校正: Hisayuki Kamon
［人生の６割の勝負？］
人生の６割の勝負
これ何だと思います？
［人生の６割が仕事］
グーグルで先生に仕事の時間を聞いたら
こんな資料できました
そして人生の６割が仕事の時間なんです
［仕事って、どう選ぶ？］
仕事ってどうやって選べばいいのか
人生の６割ですからね 難しいですよ
僕 ず～っと迷ってた
これ迷ったことある人って
どれぐらいいらっしゃいます?
ですよね
これ誰も手が上がらなかったら
ここでトーク終了しようと思ってました
人生のこうね 社会人への一歩
そして社会人になっても迷う一歩
それが
仕事の選択なんです
今日は僕 僕流の仕事の選択の
話をしに来ました
僕のこのアイデアのおかげで
僕はこの20年間 もうね 仕事が
楽しくて楽しくて楽しくてたまらない
いっさい休みたくない
逆に僕の仲間が
会社に入って うつになり
つらい思いをしました
で そいつに今日のトークを聞かせたいな
って思って作って来ました
今日のアイデアは仕事のストレスとかも
消せるアイデアだって自信があります
では僕がどんな仕事を選んだのか
［ギャンブルって運勝負?］
そう 僕プロギャンブラーなんです
プロギャンブラーで検索していただくと
トップ10個の内９個くらいが僕になってます
すごいでしょう？ 独占状態です
この中で「ギャンブラーって
運勝負じゃないの？」っていう方
少ないですね 逆に
えとね 運勝負なんです 逆に 合ってます
勇気を持って手を上げてくださって
ありがとうございます
運勝負なんです
ただ1日単位は運勝負だけど
月単位 年単位になると
スキル勝負になってきます
人生も直感とかで選びすぎると
運の要素がたくさん出てきます
運っていうのは必ず平均化して収束してきます
そうするとその運頼りの一歩に 大きな
選択肢のとき なってしまう場合があります
僕はプロです
ギャンブルは数学です
カジノにコンピューターを
持ち込んではいけません
逆に自分がコンピューター化すれば
勝てるギャンブルっていうのが存在します
プロギャンブラーとは 確率と統計を駆使し
客観的視点 俯瞰的視点 長期的視点から
ベストな一歩を導き出し
それをきっちり実行していきます
自分をコンピューター化する
それに毎日13時間
丸２年の月日がかかりました
そのおかげで15年間
カジノで勝ち続けたお金で 世界を６周したり
ギャンブルの世界で神の領域と言われる
勝率９割に辿り着いたりしました
運勝負 それをスキル勝負にしていく場合
圧倒的な努力の字 必要です
でその努力 それに何が必要かっていうのは
「好き」っていう要素なんです
［好きを仕事にするって？
一番好きな飲食を思い浮かべて］
好きを仕事にするってどう思います？
好きを仕事にしたら好きじゃなくなる
と聞いたことあるかもしれないです
僕ね そんな人に言いたい
あなたの好きはたいして好きじゃないよと
だって思い浮かべてください
一番好きな飲食
それを例えばラーメン、スイーツ
カレー、コーヒー、ビール
毎日食べて 毎日飲んで
どう？
そんな仕事してって言われたら
休みたくないでしょう？
毎日できるし好きなままでしょう？
好きってね 何度も何度も何度もできるんです
好きってね 継続するから実力が
じわじわって上がっていくんです
好きってね 壁が来ても乗り越えよう
っていう気持ちになるんです
そして僕の好きってね
カジノ勝負で勝ちたいんです
カジノの場合
英語の文献で勉強する必要性がある
ってあとでわかりました
僕 もともと英語は興味なかったんです
でも
800冊も本を読んで勉強して
まとめて暗記して
そして何が起こったか
好きってね
勝負士の僕が 英語すら喋れるようになった
そんな素敵なことがいっぱい舞い降りてきます
［なぜ、プロギャンブラーを選んだの？
♪ドラムロール♪お願いします♪］
そしてその僕は何かというと
そのプロギャンブラーなんですけど
皆によく聞かれることが
「なぜプロギャンブラーって
仕事選んだんですか？」
これすごい聞かれる
で 今日はこの答えを
皆にメインのメッセージとしてお伝えしたいです
発表します
一緒にドラムロールをお願いします
ドゥルルル ルルル ルルル
ジャン
休みたくない仕事を選べ
大事なことなので２度言いますよ
仕事の選び方をお伝えします
休みたくない仕事の条件作り
そして表作りになります
孫子の兵法に
「敵を知り己を知れば百戦危うからず」
って言葉があります
素敵なお言葉です
己を知り つまり自分を知れば
勝ちへの一歩になるんです
じゃ自分はどんな仕事の条件が
ふさわしいのか考えてほしい
そしてリストアップしてください
さらにそのリストアップが終わったら
今度は表にしてほしいんです
比較表になりますこれ
そして一個一個の条件に対して
点数をつけていただきたいんです
例えば② 僕 睡眠大好きです
今日もさっきそこで寝てました 少し
② 例えばギャンブラー
いくらでも寝れるから5点とか
で表を付けてトータルの点数
どっちかが１点でも上になります ほぼほぼ
でその時その点数に従って
自分の決断をしていくんです
これがギャンブラーっぽい視点です
数値化して俯瞰して考えて決断していく
例えばここだと17
ああ僕はギャンブラーで行こうとか
じっくり考えて理論づけてるんで
メンタルもぶれないし後悔することもない
そして壁は必ず来ますけど
ベストな一歩って自信があるんで
乗り越えてやろう
打ち勝ってやろう 必ず思います
必ずどこかに皆さんもね
最高得点の仕事ってのがあるんです
それをぜひ つかみとっていただきたいんです
一つ一つ ベターの積み重ね
ああこっちの方が
じゃ秘書よりギャンブラーの方がいいな
そんな感じで自分のをとる
そうすると人生の６割が
ハッピーな時間になります
どれくらいハッピーかというと
僕 休みたくない仕事を選んで20年になります
この20年間でいっさい休みたくない
起きたら仕事行ける喜び
そしてカジノにもスキップが如くに行く
週２でお休み 普通そうかもしれない
僕は休みたくないんで
休みより仕事の方が楽しいんです
で 仕事をずっとしてます
そうするとすごい良い結果が現れたり
楽しい なんか素敵なお話いただいたり
こうね 正のスパイラル 上昇していくんです
でもまた休みたくなくなる
休みたくない仕事を選ぶと
こんなハッピーになれる かもなんです
でも僕はこれを自信をもって勧めたいから
皆さんに今日シェアしに来ました
ちょっとここで
トーンを変えさせていただきます
今日はもう一つお伝えしたいんです
休みたくない仕事を選べの逆も真なり
休みたい仕事を選ぶな
自分がベストな選択をした場合
そのあとベストかどうかってのは
また別個の問題なんです
例えばギャンブルだけじゃない
それビジネスでも
恋愛 結婚でもそうです
例えば 僕 ポーカープロです
こっちの一番見て左手ですね
一番良い手 僕が持ちました
それでも勝負していくと
悪い手の2人に2回に1回負けてしまうんです
これは人生に置き換えて何かというと
今ベストでも来年ベストかどうかは
全然わからないよ
ただ来年ベストな可能性が
あるよと言うことなんです
仕事も一緒です
「もう無理かも」
このキーワードが大事です
「もう無理かも」ってな
ストレスがあらわれた どうする？
たたかう じゅもん にげる
これちなみにあれです
3択です 考えてください
これはスペインのトマト祭り
行った時の写真です
かわいいでしょう？
挙手でお願いします
「たたかう」という人
少ないですね けっこう 思ったより
じゃ 「じゅもん」をとなえちゃうよって人
絶対おかしいから ここの会場
（笑）
皆 気をつけて 今日の人たち
じゃ 「にげる」っていう人
そう 逃げてください
何かというと プロギャンブラーのテクニックで
ウォーキングっていうのがあります
このカジノに来ました
この中で必ずベストに勝てるところの
テーブルがどこかにあるはずなんです
で それを敵を見て 誰がカモ 誰がプロ
どうなのって
真剣に空気を読み取っていきます
それがプロのテクニック
ただプロでも「あれ？今日は勝ち目ないな」
っていうときがあるんです
勝てない勝負はする価値がないんです
勝つために逃げる
例えば 僕は吹雪の中でカジノに
勝負に行った時があります
プロだってマークされたんで
7日間連続で
行って5、6時間滞在して
また帰って つまり逃げて
7日連続で逃げたこととかある
もうね 逃げる一歩が
でも 勝ちへの一歩なんです
話を戻します 「もう無理」って言葉が
もし心の中で聞こえたら従ってほしいんです
勝つために逃げてほしい
僕はね 仕事だけじゃなくてこれ
いじめとか 家庭環境 DVでも
同じだって考えてます
「もう無理」って心の言葉が聞こえたら
必ず猛ダッシュで逃げてください
どこかにさらに連絡してください
そうしたら必ずどこかで
あなたのその声を 悩みを
聞いてくれる人は必ずいますから
だってね 世の中 まじめすぎる人
つらい思いをしちゃうんです
がまんしすぎちゃうんです
僕を見て もうね 適当なとこあって
ポイポイする能力いっぱい持ってるんです
そこをまねてほしいんです 皆に
このね まじめすぎポイポ～イ♪
これ復唱してもらっていいですか？
（笑）
行きますよ
まじめすぎポイポ～イ♪
（まじめすぎポイポ～イ♪）
ちょっとちょっとちょっとちょっと
待ってください
全然このへんね まだまじめいっぱい
このへんまだ「ポイポイ」
いっぱい残っている
動画をご覧の皆さんもご一緒にお願いしますよ
行きます
まじめすぎポイポ～イ♪
（まじめすぎポイポ～イ♪）
ありがとうございます！
素敵！
ストレスを減らせる
これが「じゅもん」になります
最後にまとめさせてください
休みたくない仕事を選んで僕20年になります
どの一歩も
「愛しい」「素敵だ」って思うくらいな
一歩に変われたんです
だからこそ今日皆にシェアしに来たんです
仕事を選ぶ選択としての一歩
休みたくない仕事を選べ
そしてストレスを減らすための一歩
「も～無理」なら逃げよう
この２つ この２つで
皆と一緒に素敵な一歩
歩みたいと思います
ご清聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）